tropical storm warnings and watches are
in place in coastal North Carolina this
morning because of Hurricane Maria the
category one storm is about 350 miles
off the coast with winds of 80 miles an
hour
the hurricane could deliver a storm
surge to the Outer Banks as early as
tomorrow the storm is expected to start
to move out to sea on Thursday Puerto
Rico's governor is calling on the
Pentagon for more help after Hurricane
Maria devastated much of the island the
majority of the territories 3.4 million
American citizens are still without
power five days after the storm made
landfall at least 10 people were killed
some are criticizing president Trump's
lack of response former Secretary of
State Hillary Clinton tweeted that the
president and defense secretary should
send the Navy to help David beg no is at
the San Juan Airport David good morning
good morning
it is a sweatbox in here there are
probably I'd estimate about a thousand
people in this terminal waiting to get a
flight most of them have tickets but
some were told to leave last night to go
sleep in another terminal and now they
got here and they're in the back of the
line this morning themselves with
cardboard and they've been doing it for
more than 72 hours even longer
it's just tough it's hot constantly
there's nowhere to lie down San Juans
main airport looks like a shelter
hundreds of people slept on their
suitcases we have got very little money
we can just about scrape together once
I'm Regine per day sue Parker eventually
got more cash but his resources are
running out people are growing desperate
seafood that's not enough the gas is not
enough so everybody's fighting to get
out whatever it is having loaded across
the area Porto Ricans are waiting in
long lines to buy fuel at gas stations
in the hard-hit region of Toa Baja
hundreds of people have stood under a
cell phone tower searching for a signal
to let their loved ones know they're
okay
on the northwestern corner of the island
officials worry this 90 year old dam is
in danger of breaching after Maria
dropped more than 15 inches of rain
70,000 people were warned of flash
flooding along the river in Isabella
your town you've evacuated everyone yes
everyone Mayor Carlos Delgado says a dam
failure would be catastrophic for people
living in his city of Isabela and other
towns that rely on this for drinking
water drinking water is so scarce in
some areas that people have been
collecting it on the side of the road in
other places it's everywhere choking
entire neighborhoods carmen barratto's
home was destroyed if I see defend it's
not easy to start again she said I don't
have anything back here at the airport
it's becoming somewhat confrontational
as people are yelling at the gate agents
saying I have been waiting for days with
children Gil here's one of the reasons
so few commercial flights are able to
get onto the island the hurricane
destroyed one of the transmission towers
at the airport reducing the radar that
pilots need to fly in and that's one
reason so many of these people have been
waiting to get off this island alright
David thank you very much David the more
you hear the worse it is I know people
who still haven't heard from relatives
in Puerto Rico
they're taking the no news is good news
but they just can't get any kind of
communication I think there's a real
question about whether the Pentagon
should be sending additional resources
to help people they're very scary so we
should at that point yeah it did
thank you again David Begg know he's
reporting from Puerto Rico